when when you're a professional fighter
and we've gone through this with Logan
Paul and Dylan danis they're I can't
emphasize this enough the number one
rule in fighting the number one rule
there's no suing in fighting and you
could have use this opportunity to gain
some fans and to gain some respect and
go cool bro send me your address I'm GNA
drive down there and beat the [__] out
of you we'd all go damn you wouldn't
watch that you wouldn't watch on
Instagram live or Tik Tok live or
Twitter live Ian Gary pulls up at Sean
Strickland's gym five round sparring
two-minute
break
what
$29.99 we make
merch what there's so much opportunity
here but you wasted it you threatened
lawsuit number one rule in prize
fighting you don't Sue each other I
can't emphasize enough